I'm obsessed with you in this show thank
you I saw three episodes and I want more
amazing so November first I'm gonna be
watching but how did you feel reading
the script for the first time because
Emily Dickinson could go very dramatic
and this has a lot of humor it does well
one thing I love about this show and
when I read it for the first time the
way that her poetry is used in this in
this series is so smart and her poetry
consists of I mean every possible
emotion and sometimes the reality of the
you know tragedy that she goes through
in life is slightly humorous and can be
and we we definitely found those those
moments and and found the light and the
heart and the humor which is so fun
because it has that and it has these
more dramatic moments so let's get a
little bit of everything it's kind of
funny too because like she has a bit of
an obsession with death in the series
and when I think about death I used to
be terrified of it um now moving forward
I feel like I've lived a good life I
feel like I'm okay when it's my time
it's my time where do you stand with
things right now I think that and I mean
just to bring it to the show for a
second I mean I do think that there
there is this sort of weight that comes
with the thought of death and I think in
Emily's poetry she speaks about it in
such light she speaks about death as as
if it's life it is it's it's another
life it's where you can go to be free
and creative and there's no constraints
there's no one telling you who or what
you can or cannot be and I think that I
sort of have this and her to thank for
that new outlook on on it myself because
I do feel like that's that's that's all
it is yeah
I love that this show touches on queer
representation and you have always been
a huge ally for the lgbtq+ community
why do you connect to that community
I think that I just I just don't
world in which people feel a certain
pressure to be a certain way or behave a
certain way is so absurd to me and I
think that there have been countless
times in my life where I've been in
situations where I feel that that sort
of pressure and and I don't anymore I
don't feel like I should and I don't
think anyone should I think everyone
should feel free to be who they are and
true to themselves and I I think having
the show deals with it so well you know
in that time maybe they didn't have the
terminology of what we have today in
terms of describing a human and maybe
that's why they have I mean you would
think they had more freedom then but it
was it was almost more forbidden then
and and it's crazy that in this show we
still deal with today what they were
dealing with then and although we've
come a long way not much has changed
which is insane to me but I just truly
believe that everyone is everyone is
equal everyone as human everyone has a
beating heart and feels the same
feelings when is everyone is equal
everyone is human everyone has a beating
heart and feels the same feelings and
maybe not but they should all be
accepted and yeah that's after life is
such a hauntingly beautiful song I gotta
tell you I have danced so many times to
love myself is such a such an anthem
thank you when we get a new album or a
full-length I mean I'm obsessed thank
you so much I know I've been working on
the music for quite some time but
wonderful opportunities like like this
one will come about and sort of take me
away from the music for a bit but it
never stops I haven't stopped writing
for a while and I have this character
that I've embodied to thank for a new
found fearlessness in in my writing that
will be coming early next year another
myself no I don't want
thank you thank you